So by this point, we've totally conquered Ambiguity, right?
Ah--not so right.
Even if I know whether an operation
is Left or Right Associative,
I'm still not sure, when there are multiple operations, which one to do first.
I could do the Multiplication first,
and get: 8 + 6 is 14
or I could do the Addition first,
and get: 2 * 10 is 20.
This isn't the same problem as associativity
because it's not about whether we're associating to the Left or the Right,
it's about the--sort of the precedence of these Operators.
which one is more important,
which one should I deal with first--
which one binds more tightly.
In Standard mathematics, we'd want to do the multiplication first.
Multiplication has higher precedence than Addition.
It gets serviced first.